so what's the BMA said about the results
of this ballot
well the BMA says they've got a huge
mandate from their members for this walk
out that they've had a record turnout at
98 of those who voted were in favor of
strike action importantly this
industrial action will include emergency
care so this is important because trust
will have to organize their own
emergency cover in order to keep
patients safe but the BMA has said that
they will give them enough notice to be
able to do this and they say they'll
simply ran out of options to try to
secure better pay for their members who
they say have got a real terms pay cut
of 25 over the last 15 years now the
union says that this makes it difficult
not just to recruit new doctors into the
profession but also to retain the
existing doctors which in turn creates a
crisis in Staffing and makes it
difficult to provide appropriate care
for patients and also to try to tackle
that huge NHS backlog of nearly 7
million people people waiting for an
appointment or for an operation now on
the other hand the government says that
what the union is asking for is
unaffordable Steve Barkley the health
secretary has released a statement
saying that he was disappointed that
some Junior doctors have decided to go
on strike and that as part of a
multi-year deal already agreed with a
BMA Junior doctors had a pay rise of
about 8.2 percent in the last three
years it's important to know that for
this Current financial year that that
pay rise was two percent which the union
says is Holy inadequate the government
also said that they increased pay for
night shifts so I think that really
shows that there are two sides are at
such Polar Opposites and neither of them
seems to be budging so it's hard to see
how this dispute will progress and all
the while the NHS just continues under
strain